[Musik]
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ihr
nach dem über ein Jahr lang das
russische Desaster in der Ukraine mit
ansehen mussten davon überzeugt seit
Moskau habe seine ganze militärische
Macht gegen seine Nachbaren im Westen
geworfen und ja in gewisser Weise stimmt
das auch Russland hat seine
hauptkampfverbände bereits in die
Ukraine geschickt und dabei mehr als
200.000 Soldaten und 2000 Panzer
verloren das macht mehr als die Hälfte
seiner gesamten relevanten Panzer
Reserven aus und das ist nur ein
Beispiel trotzdem stoßen wir
gleichzeitig auch auf Nachrichten wie
diese der Sudan schlittert ins Chaos
Russland lauert im Hintergrund
USA machen die russische wagnergruppe
für die Verschlechterung der
Sicherheitslage in Mali verantwortlich
und ich denke dass ich euch jetzt fragt
welches Interesse hat Russland
ausgerechnet am Sudan oder einmali ich
meine Russland ist hier und Mali ist
dort also ich weiß nicht auf den ersten
Blick scheint diese Nachricht nicht viel
Sinn zu machen oder ich meine was juckt
ist die Russen was gerade in Afrika
abgeht doch wenn ihr so Politik schon
länger verfolgt wisst ihr bereits das
Russland überall auf der Welt seine
Tentakel im Spiel hat Putins
ursprünglicher Masterplan war ja die
Errichtung eines großrussischen Reiches
als globales Supermacht über diesen
haben wir schon ein eigenes Video
gedreht dass ich euch verlinkt werde
aber auch wenn diese Welt
Eroberungspläne momentan in der Nähe
einer ostukrainischen Kleinstadt ein
wenig ins Stocken geraten sind von
seiner globalen Agenda ist Putin nicht
abgerückt ganz im Gegenteil gerade jetzt
braucht er Afrika mehr denn je und jetzt
werden sich sicher einige Fragen warum
braucht er denn gerade Afrika und wieso
ausgerechnet jetzt wo er doch in der
Ukraine alle Hände voll zu tun hat nun
überlegt mal bis 2022 kontrollierte
Russland einen sehr klaren
Einflussbereich in Zentralasien und im
Kaukasus aber ein Jahr später bröckelt
all diese Macht dahin Kasachstan
entfernt sich immer weiter von der
russischen Einflusssphäre und dann ist
da natürlich der Konflikt zwischen
Armenien und dabei Schaden der Berg
Karbach Streit ja Jahrzehnte lang hat
Russland in diesem Streit die Rolle des
Schiedsrichters gespielt ganz nach dem
Motto teile und herrsche aber jetzt ist
es kaum mehr präsent und es wird auch
nicht erwartet dass ich das allzu bald
wieder ändern wird andere Spieler treten
in diese Lücke die Türkei der Iran sogar
westliche Staaten zeigen verstärktes
Interesse an der Region wieder besucht
worden sind die nach Medien letzten
Herbst deutlich gezeigt hat hinzu kommt
das einige weitere Länder die früher in
Moskau aus Orbit kreisten dieser Tage
zunehmend nach Peking blicken Afrika
jedoch steht weiterhin im Zentrum der
Agenda des Krems genauer gesagt auf der
Agenda der berüchtigten wagnergruppe
geliebte Dokumente zeigen Wagnis
einflussreiche weit über die Ukraine
hinaus einem vertraulichen Dokument zur
Folge trafen sich Abgesandte von Wagner
im Februar heimlich mit türkischen
Kontakten und schlichten sich auf der
Suche nach Waffen und Ausrüstung für den
Kampf in der Ukraine auf den NATO
Territorium das Dokument in dem das
Treffen in der Türkei beschrieben wird
liegt nahe dass der westafrikanische
Staat Mali in dem Wagner einen wichtigen
Außenposten eingerichtet hat als Proxy
fungieren und die Waffen im Namen
Wagners von der Türkei beziehen könnte
in einem anderen Dokument wird ein
Wagner mit Liz zitiert das mehr als
1.645 Wagner Truppen in Mali stationiert
sind was Sicherheit Bedenken in der
benachbarten Elfenbeinküste ausgelöst
hat
[Musik]
ihr wisst bereits dass die wagnergruppe
eine private sölde-organisation ist im
Grunde eine Privatarmee in
putinsdiensten ihr eigentümerie ist ein
enger Freund des Präsidenten wir reden
hier von einer Gruppierung die kein
Problem darin sieht Kriegsgefangenen da
erschmäßig den Kopf abzusteigen
vermeintliche Deserteure mit dem
Vorschlaghammer zu exekutieren und ihre
eigenen Männer in frontalen Sturm
Angriffen gegen weit überlegene
ukrainische Verteidiger zu schicken auch
wenn das bedeutet die kopfüber in einen
erbarmungslosen Fleischwolf zu stürzen
aber die Musiker wie sich die Leute von
Wagner gern selbst nennen sind nicht nur
in der Ukraine aktiv sie spielen ihr
Lied vom Tod auch in Afrika und zwar
auch ganz handfesten eigenen Interessen
jetzt auch bei den Sudan Unruhen Putins
Kampf um Afrika wie Gefechte im Sudan
haben eine russische Handschrift die
über das Land hinausweist ein Mann
spielt dabei eine besondere Rolle die
derzeitigen Kämpfe im Sudan wo sich zwei
Generäle bekriegen werden ebenfalls von
pregorian befeuert der Mann der seine
Karriere als gastronomieunternehmer
Putins Koch begonnen hat brachte das
zynische Kunststück fertig beide
Konfliktparteien mit Waffen auszustatten
im Gegenzug erhielt er Goldminen
Rangerin macht in kleinen vor wie Putin
im großen operiert russland ist der
wichtigste rüstungslieferant für Afrika
und die Hälfte aller registrierten
waffenverkäufer kommen von dort darüber
hinaus bilden Russen Militärs aus auch
im Bürgerkriegsland Mali aus dem sich
die Bundeswehr und andere europäische
Kräfte zurückziehen die Frage lautet
also weshalb genau sie dort sind und
inwieweit sich die afrikanischen Länder
dem russischen Einfluss wiedersetzen nun
die traurige Wahrheit ist dass viele
dieser Länder leider so arm sind dass
sie es sich oft nicht leisten können
eindringende Truppen abzuwehren nicht
einmal private Truppen wie die von
Wagner doch die wichtigste Frage die wir
uns stellen müssen lautet ist Russland
die einzige auswärtige macht die in
Afrika Präsenz zeigt offensichtlich
nicht denn es gibt ein weiteres
europäisches Land das seine imperialen
Träume nie aufgegeben hat von welchem
Land hier die Sprache ist ganz genau
Frankreich treue visualpolitik Zuschauer
werden bereits wissen dass Frankreich
seine ehemaligen Kolonien nie ganz
aufgegeben hat und sie werden auch
wissen dass der französische
Kolonialismus alles andere als
freundlich war wir haben über
Frankreichs postkoloniale Machenschaften
zum Beispiel Messer als ohne sogar schon
ein eigenes Video gedreht dass ich euch
verlinken werde hatte SD granation in
Afrika jedoch meist nur mit lokalen
Potentaten zu tun hat der Einfluss
Russland insbesondere mit dem Aufkommen
von Wagner in Afrika tatsächlich so
einiges auf den Kopf gestellt und ihr
werdet euch fragen wie viel Einfluss
kann eine Gruppe russische Söldner wie
die wagnertruppe denn wirklich haben nun
es handelt sich sicherlich um alles
andere als eine Bagatelle schaut euch
mal diese Karte an
obwohl die russische Präsenz sicherlich
nicht der einzige Grund ist warum
Frankreich nach wie vor bedeutende
Truppenkontingent in Afrika unterhält
ist es eine Tatsache dass dieser Grund
in letzter Zeit immer wichtiger geworden
ist um euch eine Vorstellung davon zu
geben die Truppenzahl die Frankreich
seit 2013 in der Sahelzone stationiert
hat beläuft sich heute auf mehr als 3000
Soldaten und vor dem Rückzug aus Mali in
den letzten Jahres waren es sogar 5.100
russland hat bereits 3000 Zöllner in
Afrika es ist klar dass es weniger
Russen als Franzosen sind aber es
handelt sich um vergleichbare Zahlen und
das obwohl Russland momentan wahrlich
noch andere Fronten offen hat natürlich
sind auch internationale Kräfte wie die
un-blau-helme in der Region präsent aber
um es klar zu sagen die UN ist nicht
gerade ein Allheilmittel wenn es um
Macht und Einfluss geht eines ist
jedenfalls unbestreitbar was den
politischen Einfluss angeht bleibt
Frankreich die größte ausländische macht
in der Region und mit Sicherheit ist
seine Präsenz viel größer als die
Russlands es unterhält mehr Militärbasen
mehr Kontakte in der Region und stärkere
wirtschaftliche Beziehungen zu den
relevanten Staaten doch wurde pc-palast
früher praktisch der einzige Sheriff in
der Stadt war bekommen die Franzosen
heute Konkurrenz durch zwei weitere
Mächte China und Russland wir haben hier
auf visualpolitik bereits ausführlich
über Chinas Präsenz in Afrika gesprochen
im heutigen Video konzentrieren wir uns
daher auf Russland die Frage ist also
wie stark bröckelt die französische
Dominanz in Zentral und Westafrika was
kann Frankreich tun um in der Region
stark zu bleiben warum ist die
französische Präsenz dort so wichtig
welche Interessen verfolgt Russland und
welche Bedeutung könnte das alles für
den Krieg in der Ukraine haben heute
werden wir all diese Fragen natürlich
beantworten und zwar gleich nach einer
wichtigen Botschaft unseres tollen
Sponsors der dieses Video möglich
gemacht hat denn surfshark hat ein VPN
im Angebot das wirklich empfehlenswert
und vor allem sicher und
vertrauenswürdig ist so lockt es zum
Beispiel selbstverständlich keinerlei
Verbindungsdaten mit natürlich kann ein
Wäsche private Network VPN einen nicht
vor allem gefahrenschützen gegen das
lauern man muss nach wie vor
unsichthalten lassen und wissen was man
tut aber es stellt hier für ein Werkzeug
mit gleich mehreren Vorteilen darf zum
einen Erwerb ist ein Kombination mit
anderen Vorkehrungen eure Kombination im
letzten nachzuverfolgen und abzuhören
mit Hilfe verschiedener
Sicherheitsfeatures könnt ihr so eure
Anonymität im Netz erhöhen zum Beispiel
mit dem integrierten klimap das alle
unerwünschten Cookies und Poppers blockt
weiterer Vorteil eines Väter ist dass
ihr so tun könnt als wäret ihr an einem
anderen Ort so könnt ihr zum Beispiel
auch Webseite und Internetdienste
zugreifen die in dem Land in ihr gerade
seid nicht verfügbar werden ob daheim
oder auch Reisen damit schlagt ihr
Zensur und jur blocking ein Schnäppchen
Netflix und anderes
anbieten von Europa ausnutzen oder
deutsches Internet fernsehen im Ausland
gucken mit kein Problem aber das ist
noch lange nicht alles damit nur zur
Kontakte wirklich alle eure Endgeräte
MVB registrieren Handys Notebooks oder
sogar euren Smart TV so und wenn ihr den
Rabattcode politik.de angeht bekommt
und sage und schreibe 83 brauchst du
noch obendrein noch drei Monate gratis
dazu den Link zu diesem Angebot findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video also nichts los besorgt euch
surfshoppen greift damit auch
gleichzeitig uns finanzieren unter die
Arme das könnt ihr übrigens auch direkt
mit Hilfe des Spenden Links die ich euch
ebenfalls in die Beschreibung gepackt
habe wir sind euch für jede
Unterstützung dankbar denn damit hätte
uns offen in Zukunft noch mehr und noch
bessere Videos zu liefern so und nun
begeben wir uns auf eine Reise nach
Afrika um unsere brennenden Fragen zu
beantworten wie stark bröckelt die
französische Dominanz in Zentral und
Westafrika was kann Frankreich tun um in
der Region stark zu bleiben warum ist
die französische Präsenz doch überhaupt
so wichtig welche Interessen verfolgt
Russland und welche Bedeutung könnte das
alles für den Krieg in der Ukraine haben
wieso oft tauchen wir zu ihrer
Verantwortung zunächst in die Geschichte
ab in die düstere Geschichte des
französischen Kolonialismus
[Musik]
französischer Kolonialismus
wenn es etwas gibt dem wir hier auf
visualpolitik dauerhaft entgegentreten
dann ist es der Kolonialismus aber
versteht uns nicht falsch es geht uns
hier nicht darum auf eine hippenwelle
der westlichen selbstgeistlung zu
schwimmen ich meine sicherlich wird
heute niemand mehr sagen lasst uns
Indien und Afrika wieder zu Kolonien
machen die können es doch gar nicht
selber nun vielleicht gibt es den ein
oder anderen der diese Meinung vertritt
aber von uns werdet ihr solche Sätze
sicherlich nicht hören wir denken jedoch
dass Kolonialismus und seine Folgen ein
sehr vielfältiges Thema sind das sehr
differenziert gesehen werden muss oft
aber oberflächlich über einen Kamm
geschert oder sehr einseitig bzw
ideologisiert diskutiert wird dazu
gehört zum Beispiel das weitgehende
Schweigen über den muslimisch arabischen
Kolonialismus und Sklavenhandel der
sogar weitaus größer war als der
europäischen nordamerikanische besonders
zynisch und rassistisch ist daher auch
die Gleichsetzung aller Europäer bzw
Kaukasien mit Nachfahren von
Kolonisatoren und Sklavenhaltern und
aller anderen mit deren Opfern das ist
natürlich totaler Quatsch schließlich
wurde selbst das Wort das klar wird
nicht als völlig von Slava abgeleitet
und die Slawen sind schließlich die
größte europäische Ethnie bei vielen
Sklaven muss es sich also offensichtlich
um Slawen gehandelt haben auch wenn
einige Ostslawen dann selbst
synchronisatoren geworden sind die halb
Asien unterworfen haben fakt ist
Europäer waren nicht die einzigen Täter
und sehr viele von ihnen waren sogar
Opfer und wir sollten auch nicht
vergessen dass nicht alle Fälle von
Kolonialismus gleich waren es gab
Kolonialreiche die einige
Regierungsstrukturen beibehalten haben
und dann entweder freiwillig oder weil
sie rausgeworfen wurden komplett
abgezogen das war zum Beispiel der
Verspannungen und der meisten seine
amerikanischen Kolonie unser Protagonist
in diesem Video frankreich hat jedoch
genau das Gegenteil getan denn was sich
die gehorsamation bis weit ins 20
Jahrhundert hinein geleistet hat ist
schon eine besonders stark
Frankreich kam zu spät zur ersten
kolonisierungswelle und hat deshalb bei
der Aufteilung von Mittel- und
Südamerika praktisch nichts mehr
abbekommen trotzdem gelang es den
Franzosen einen großen Teil Nordamerikas
und später auch bedeutende Gebiete in
Südostasien zu erobern allerdings war
diese Periode nicht der Höhepunkt des
französischen Imperiums nein als dieser
gilt er das 19 Jahrhundert während
Spanien damals in einer tiefen Krise
steckte und 1898 in der letzten
amerikanischen Kolonien und die
Philippinen verloren erlebte Frankreich
nach der Berliner kongo-konferenz von
1884/85 einen Aufschwung den Franzosen
gelang es sich zusammen mit
Großbritannien als größtes Kolonialreich
in Afrika zu etablieren es stimmt zwar
dass ihre ersten Siedlungen auf dem
Kontinent auf die Mitte des 17
jahrhunderts im Senegal zurückgehen und
dass sie bereits zwischen 1840 und 50
Gebiete wie die Elfenbeinküste sogar und
Algerien unter ihre Kontrolle gebracht
hatten aber 1885 erreicht das
französische Imperium seinen Höhepunkt
plötzlich macht ihre Dominanzen Afrika
den dritten einen Strich durch die
Rechnung Frankreichs letzte wirklich
alles daran den eigenen Profit aus
diesen Kolonien zu maximieren alles aus
ihnen herauszuholen sei es nun Gold
ausmali oder oberwolter dem heutigen
Faso Frankreich barbestrebte so viele
Bodenschätze wie möglich auszubeuten
und es wird euch nicht überraschen dass
der Aufbau von stabilen Institutionen
und Infrastrukturen nicht ganz oben auf
ihrer Liste stand um ehrlich zu sein sie
waren dort um die Ressourcen auszubeuten
Punkt sie hatten absolut kein Interesse
daran ihre Kolonien über das hinaus zu
entwickeln was notwendig war damit ihre
Förderanlagen mit voller Kapazität
Arbeiten konnten tatsächlich ist die
französische Kolonialherrschaft auf ganz
besonders unheimliche Weise in die
Geschichte eingegangen weil sie zu den
brutalsten gehörte wie die Massaker in
den algerischen Städten sind tief und
immer beispielhaft zeigen natürlich
werden jetzt einige sagen dass die
Nachbarn der Franzosen die Belgier im
Kongo ja noch viel schrecklichere Gold
hatten verübt haben aber diese absolute
Terrorherrschaft anzuführen wäre der
totale Worte bautismus die Verbrechen
der Franzosen sind durch nichts zu
entschuldigen und Fakt ist auch dass sie
am liebsten einfach weitergemacht hätten
wenn es nach ihnen gegangen wäre aber
zum Glück ging es nicht nach ihnen denn
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg fand sich
eine eher ungewöhnliche Koalition
zusammen die anfängt ordentlich Druck
auf die Kolonialmächte auszuüben und
sparen diese ungewöhnlichen Koalitionäre
gegen den Kolonialismus nun so sehr sich
die USA und die Sowjetunion auch
unterschieden sie einigten sich auf
einen gemeinsamen Punkt mit
Kolonialismus war Schluss die
Kolonialherren sollten sich aus Afrika
zurückziehen diesen Druck der Giganten
vermochten die vom Krieg geschwächten
europäischen Imperium nicht zu
widerstehen und dann ging es Schlag auf
Schlag die UNO gründete den
Sonderausschuss für Entkolonialisierung
und die Kolonialreiche begann sich Stück
für Stück aufzulösen im Zuge dieses
Prozesses liest das Vereinigte
Königreich Nigeria und alle seine
afrikanischen Kolonien hinter sich
Spanien tat dasselbe mit
Äquatorialguinea und seiner Besetzung
Marokkos aber was war mit Frankreich nun
die Realität ist mein Leben Zuschauer
dass es Frankreich extrem schwer viel
die Zügel seine Territorien loszulassen
und tatsächlich können wir dort überall
auch heute noch deutlich Überreste das
ist ehemaligen französischen Reiches
erkennen und zwar der starken Einfluss
dass die gesamte Region noch heute
francer Fried genannt hat bevor die
französischen Kolonien unabhängig wurden
hat
de Gaulle die neu in die Unabhängigkeit
entlassenen Länder dazu gebracht sind
Tieren dass ihre Währungspolitik von
Frankreich auskontrolliert wird und so
wurde der cfa-frau geboren
[Musik]
das ist das gesetzliche Zahlungsmittel
in 14 Ländern das früher an den France
und jetzt an den Euro gekoppelt ist und
wo befinden sich die größten
Währungsreserven des CFA France nun
genau in Frankreich mit anderen Worten
Paris übt bis heute eine enorme
Kontrolle über diese Volkswirtschaften
aus wenn das nicht eine krasse
Überbleibsel von Kolonialismus ist dann
weiß ich auch nicht wie man es sonst
bezeichnen soll klar einige von euch
werden jetzt einwenden na das ist doch
gar nicht mal so schlecht eine an den
Euro gekoppelte Währung zu haben
bedeutet doch auch dass diese Länder es
geschafft haben eine Hyperinflation zu
vermeiden und ja da habt ihr recht aber
Frankreichs Kontrolle beschränkt sich
nicht nur auf die Wirtschaft
Paris ist nämlich auch dafür bekannt
autoritäre Regierungen zu unterstützen
und warum fragt ihr euch vielleicht nun
die Antwort liegt in einem Wort
Bodenschätze im Grunde unterstützt
Frankreich autoritäre Regierungen im
Gegenzug dafür dass seine Konzerne beim
Abbau von Bodenschätzen bevorzugt werden
denn was glaubt ihr woher das Uran für
die berühmten französischen
Atomkraftwerke kommt nun hauptsächlich
aus Niger einer ehemaligen französischen
Kolonie wo das Unternehmen fast
vollständig kontrolliert und wenn es aus
der Bevölkerung Proteste gegen diese
autoritären Regierungen gab dann hat
Frankreich nicht gezögert seine Truppen
zu schicken diese haben die Situation
für die Diktatoren dann wieder unter
Kontrolle gebracht das lief übrigens von
Anfang an so ab wie zum Beispiel der
Staatsstreich in Gabun 1964 zeigt es war
ein putscht der nur vier Jahren nach der
Unabhängigkeit des Landes von Frankreich
stattfand mit anderen Worten die
Entkolonialisierung von Frankreich liegt
in etwa so auf keine Sorge Gabionen du
bist jetzt frei und zwar so lange Du
weiterhin genau das tust was ich von dir
will dies ist nur ein Beispiel aber beim
allgemeinen war dies das übliche
Vorgehen Frankreich neigte dazu mit
seinen ehemaligen Kolonien nach
Gutdünken zu verfahren Unabhängigkeit
hin oder her und wer zu sehr aufmuckte
von wegen souveräne Nation und so bekam
die gallische Militärmacht zu spüren das
heißt auf dem Papier war Frankreich
keine Kolonialmacht mehr vom Verhalten
her hat dies in Paris jedoch niemanden
sonderlich gejuckt man trat weiterhin
auf wieder große kolonial her und so
lief es viele jahrzehntelang ja bis mit
Beginn des neuen Jahrtausends ein neuer
Akteur auf dem Plan trat der Frankreich
ordentlich die froschsuppe versalzen
sollte wer das war aufgepasst
[Musik]
China der neue Freund
und sie wird in den Kommentaren ja oft
vorgeworfen wir würden es uns in keinem
Video nehmen lassen Russland oder China
zu bashen aber um dies an dieser Stelle
einfach allemal klarzustellen es geht
uns nie ich betone nie um irgendwelche
Nationalitäten es geht uns immer nur ums
Verhalten okay wir haben auch schon ein
Video darüber gedreht auf welche
unlauterweise China afrikanische Länder
von sich abhängig macht aber im
Vergleich zur Rolle des glorreichen
eu-gründungsmitglied Frankreich sieht
eben sogar die totalitäre groß macht
China wieder reinste weisen Knabe aus
natürlich überrascht ist wohl niemanden
aus welchen Gründen der asiatische Riese
ein wichtiger aktuellen Afrika geworden
ist Afrika verfügt über viele Ressourcen
die China braucht und china besitzt die
wirtschaftlichen Kapazitäten um
afrikanischen Ländern die Entwicklung zu
ermöglichen oder sie zumindest in die
Lage zu versetzen große
Infrastrukturprojekte zu verwirklichen
das dabei nicht immer das gelbe vom
Eifer Afrika herauskommt haben wir schon
in erwähnten Video erklärt außerdem sind
die afrikanischen Märkte noch nicht voll
erblüht so dass China die Chance sieht
von Beginn an dabei zu sein und seinen
Anteil am zu bekommen beispielsweise um
von den billigen Arbeitskräften zu
profitieren daher begangen sowohl der
chinesische Staat als auch
Privatunternehmen sich für Investitionen
afrikanischen Länder zu interessieren
allerdings gibt es auch bereits frühere
präsidenzfälle für chinesische Projekte
in Afrika von den 1960er Jahren mit der
ersten Eisenbahnlinie in Sambia bis zu
2016 fertiggestellten Verbindung
zwischen Alice Abeba und shibut die hat
China bis 2022 März 6000 km
Eisenbahnstrecken in Afrika gebaut und
nicht nur das China hat auch in den Bau
von Industrieparks Krankenhäusern
Straßen und viel mehr investiert sich an
Analysten China vergrößert seinen
Einfluss in Afrika durch
Telekommunikation na seht ihr den
Unterschied china baut nicht nur
natürliche Ressourcen ab offensichtlich
baut es im Gegenzug auch eine Menge
Dinge auf
chinat vielen afrikanischen Ländern
geholfen mit der bildverbunden zu sein
ihre Isolation zu durchbrechen und
Echtzeit-Informationen zu erhalten nicht
nur durch die Investitionen in
Telekommunikationsinfrastruktur sondern
auch durch die Herstellung
erschwingliche Handys für den
afrikanischen Markt das alles führt
natürlich auch zu kulturellen und
politischen Einfluss es wurden Dutzende
von konfuzius-instituten eröffnet in den
Chinesisch unterrichtet wird außerdem
bieten dich in diesen Fernsehsendungen
an was bedeutet das Millionen von
afrikanern-programme schauen doch trotz
all dem ist eines klar china hat Afrika
angeboten was Frankreich nie getan hat
die Chance auf Augenhöhe zu verhandeln
nun vielleicht nicht ganz aber zumindest
weniger als bloße Untertanen und mehr
als geschäftliche Juniorpartner
behandelt zu werden aber wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt ist man im elisa-palast
über diese Entwicklung Nord very News
auch wenn man Kronach außen auch mal
gerne den bürgling verschieben macht
aber machen wir uns nichts vor die
chinesischen Engagements entstehen nicht
aus purer Nächstenliebe sondern aus
harten wirtschaftlichen und
geopolitischen Interessen und die
chinesische Präsenz bewirkt auch keine
Wunder Afrika nach wie vor eine Menge
Probleme und eines der wichtigsten ist
der Radikalismus wo wollen wir hier
reden nun spritzt ist die Uhr
[Musik]
im freien Fall
bis jetzt hat Frankreich seine Einfluss
in Afrika mehr oder weniger diskret
aufrecht erhalten okay zugegeben sie
haben den ein oder anderen Staatsstreich
unterstützt sich ein verdeckten Mission
beteiligt und die ein oder andere
autoritäre Regierung gestützt das üble
Übliche eben doch 2013 gab es einen
Wendepunkt Frankreich betrat wieder die
politische Bühne Afrikas und warum nun
mal in Mali ein Bürgerkrieg ausgebrochen
war
im Jahr 2012 musste sich Mali mit der
touarek Rebellion auseinandersetzen die
im Norden des Landes von der nationalen
Bewegung zur Befreiung von aserbat
organisiert wurde diese Bewegung die
Verbindungen zu den gerhardistischen
Gruppen an Sarah DIN und al-Qaida im
islamischen maghre hat begann eine harte
aufstandskampagne gegen die zentrale
Regierung in Mali sie eroberten mehr und
mehr Gebiete und am Ende hatte Mali
keine andere Wahl als Paris um Hilfe zu
bitten so begann die operationsverwalt
für die Frankreich rund 3000 Militär
Angehörige einsetzte die Intervention
war zunächst ein Erfolg im Juni 2013
wurde mit den Touareg Frieden
geschlossen oder damalige Präsident
konnte triumphieren durch die Straßen
von Bamako der Hauptstadt von Mali
schreiben außerdem richtete die UNO eine
ständige Friedensmission ein minusma der
Frieden war jedoch nur von kurzer Dauer
und deshalb September begann die
Feindseligkeiten im Land erneut was die
Ausbreitung der distischen Terrorismus
in der gesamten Region beschleunigte
eine Terrorwelle die Mali Niger und
portina Faso besonders hart getroffen
hat
die Situation geriet so sehr außer
Kontrolle dass Frankreich mehr Truppen
entsenden musste aus der Operation
selber Ball wurde die Operation die erst
im November letzten jahresendete
[Musik]
frankreich wollte vor allem seine
Rohstoffunternehmen schützen es ging in
erster Linie um das Gold in Mali und für
die Atom macht besonders wichtig das
Uran entnieger mit anderen Worten die
Franzosen konzentrierten sich auf den
Kampf gegen den Journalismus
ausschließlich in Gebieten in denen es
für sie interessante natürliche
Ressourcen gab doch die Probleme ließen
nicht auf sich warten das größte war
wahrscheinlich die Ausbildung der
lokalen Armeen auf den ersten Blick
scheint daran nichts auszusetzen zu sein
ja es ist sogar das was ihr vielleicht
erwartet hättet aber wisst ihr was es
hat sich herausgestellt dass ich gerade
das zu einem der größten Probleme
entwickelt hat seht euch nur mal diese
Grafik an wie er erkennen könnt gab es
2020 sowohl in Burkina Faso als auch in
Mali mehr zivile Opfer durch die
nationalen Sicherheitskräfte als durch
die Dschihadisten selbst und das meine
Lieben Zuschauer ist eigentlich keine
große Überraschung überlegt mal ethische
Konflikte kommen in diesen Teil der Welt
doch ziemlich häufig vor und
normalerweise werden die armen jedes
dieser Länder von einer bestimmten
ethnischen Gruppe dominiert nun begann
Frankreich also plötzlich Armen
auszubilden den und zu unterhalten die
wiederum von einer bestimmten ethnischen
Gruppe dominiert worden und diese
ethnischen Gruppen nutzen einfach all
die französische Militärhilfe um die
anderen ethnischen Gruppen zu Wasser
kreieren braucht ihr ein Beispiel
Burkina Faso
[Musik]
die Armee wird von der Volksgruppe der
Mossi dominiert und diese zögerte keine
Sekunde lang Angehörige der Volksgruppen
der fulani und der PU zu töten und was
ist das Ergebnis wenn so etwas passiert
nun es ist so vorhersehbar wie tragisch
diejenigen die angegriffen werden suchen
nach jemanden der sie beschützt zum
Beispiel den Dschihadisten auf diese
Weise geraten wir in einen Teufelskreis
eine Spirale der Gewalt in der die
französische Hilfe gegen den
Dschihadismus zu mehr Gewalt führt und
zu mehr Dschihadismus versteht ihr jetzt
warum Frankreich in diesen Ländern
keinen allzu gutes Image hat und es
erklärt auch warum Mali im August 2022
sagte Signal Frankreich vielen Dank für
eure Hilfe aber wie wäre es wenn ihr uns
in Ruhe lasst und wie es alleine
schaffen ja der Punkt ist nun dass die
anderen Nachbarländern in genau dieselbe
Richtung schaut es euch an ohne rohen in
Burkina Faso Frankreich erklärt sich
bereits eine Truppen abzuziehen und in
einer Zeit in der sowohl das Image
Frankreichs als auch das Vertrauen in
Paris absolute Tiefpunkte erreicht haben
stellt sich die Frage wer wird die Lücke
füllen die Frankreich hinterlässt und
ich weiß was im Moment alle denkt China
richtig der chinesische Freund der die
Afrikaner gleichberechtigt behandelt sie
mit Infrastruktur unter die
Kommunikationsnetzen versorgt und ihnen
sogar bei der Industrialisierung hilft
oder warum sollten nun nicht einfach
noch Militärhilfe und chinesische
Truppen dazukommen peking will doch eine
globale Supermacht werden die es auch
militärisch mit den USA aufnehmen kann
oder nun nicht wirklich nichts könnte
nämlich weiter von der Wahrheit entfernt
sein Peking steckt nämlich in einer
militärischen Zwickmühle auch einen
Teufelskreis eigentlich müsste die
sogenannte chinesische
volksbefreiungsarmeer dringend
Erfahrungen in echten
Konfliktsituationen schließlich liegt
ihre letzte größere Konfrontation mit
einem Gegner schon mehr als vier
Jahrzehnte zurück was wäre besser
geeignet als Auslandseinsätze möchte man
meinen das Problem ist jedoch das Peking
sich vor diesen fürchtet wie der Teufel
vor dem weiberwasser denn je mehr Zeit
verstreicht desto mehr Unsicherheit
besteht über die tatsächliche praktische
Kampfstärke der chinesischen Armee und
zwar auch bei der Armee und
Parteiführung selbst sie sind einfach
nicht in der Lage einzuschätzen wie
Chinesisch Einsätze zum Beispiel gegen
Dschihadisten letztlich ausgehen würden
und wohin sie am Ende führen würden
Peking ist bei seinen muskelspielen und
Drohgebärden gegenüber Taiwan und
anderen revalien Pazifik jedoch zwingend
darauf angewiesen auf gar keinen Fall
Schwäche zu zeigen oder gar als
militärischer Versager dazustehen wie
die USA eine Afghanistan oder Russland
jetzt in der Ukraine der größte
anzunehmende Unfall für die an
nationalistisch militaristischen Töne
nie sparsamen Kader wäre wenn Sie sowohl
den USA Teil waren Indien Japan Südkorea
und Vietnam als auch den eigenen
Untertanen den Beweis liefern würden
dass ihre Soldaten trotzdem moderner
Militärtechnik selbst gegen Rebellen in
Afrika nicht richtig kämpfen können
Ahnen tun sie das nämlich sowieso schon
lange aber das ist eine Geschichte von
ganz anderes Video okay wenn es also
nicht China ist das einspringt dann wird
es endlich Zeit für
die Umarmung des russischen Bären
habt ihr euch eigentlich schon mal die
Flagge von Mosambik einer ehemaligen
portugiesischen Kolonie genauer
angesehen wahrscheinlich eher nicht also
es ist diese hier seht ihr irgendwas
ungewöhnliches etwas das euch jetzt Auge
sticht richtig das was ihr da über Kreuz
mit der Hacke seht ist eine russische
Kalaschnikow mit montierten bionette und
deren bekannt dass das Subtyp die AK47
ist wohl einer der berühmtesten
sturmgewehr-typen überhaupt und
natürlich ein sowjetischer
Exportschlager und auch wenn uns das
alles etwas merkwürdig und vor allem
makaber erscheinen mag es ergibt allen
Sinn der Welt denn tatsächlich warum
Kalaschnikows in verschiedensten
Ausführungen äußerst beliebte Waffen in
Mosambik vor allem während des
unabhängigkeitsprozesses sie stellen so
mit einem Wahrzeichen der Unabhängigkeit
des Landes von den portugiesischen
kolonialen da dies verwirrt Union und
ihre Verbündeten spielten bei diesen
Prozessen in mehreren Ländern eine sehr
wichtige Rolle nicht nur durch Druck vor
der UNO sondern auch durch die
Entsendung von Rüstungsgütern Ausbildern
und Truppen wenn wir also Nachrichten
mit den Abzug der französischen Truppen
aus burgina Phase so sehen es ist nicht
schwer sich vorzustellen das Russland
versuchen könnte Frankreich in der
Region zu ersetzen
Liebe bereits zu Beginn des Videos
erwähnt haben ist Russland bereits über
die zöllnertruppe Wagner aktiv geworden
ihre Aktivitäten in Afrika begann 2017
in Libyen und im Sudan und haben heute
auch Mosambik Mali und die
Zentralafrikanische Republik erreicht
und ihr fragt euch vielleicht was das
überhaupt zu bedeuten hat was treibt
eine private Firma die in Russland
offizielle als Beratungsunternehmen
registriert ist in afrikanischen
Kriegsgebieten nun ja es handelt sich um
ein Unternehmen das einen etwas
ungewöhnlichen Service anbietet schaut
euch an
Liebesgrüße aus Moskau ein Putin
Verbündeter verbaut Gold ab und spielt
in Sudan um die Gunst des Volkes
unterstützt vom Kreml Chefin das
schattenhafte Netzwerk das also
wagnergruppe bekannt ist im Sudan
Reichtümer während es dem Militär hilft
eine Demokratie Bewegung nieder so
schlagen genau so sieht es aus meine
Lieben Zuschauer die wagnergruppe hilft
Putin beim goldgraben und das nicht nur
im Sudan sondern auch in Mali wo sie
ausbeutungsrecht an drei Goldmine
ergattert hat und in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik das
Hauptziel war jedoch immer
Faso und warum
nun weil dort jährlich 70 Tonnen Gold
gefördert werden womit das Land einer
der größten Produzenten in Afrika ist
mit anderen Worten Burkina Faso fördert
jedes Jahr so viel Gold wie Dänemark an
Goldreserven hat und es überrascht nicht
dass ich Putin bei solchen Nachrichten
die Hände reibt die wagnergruppe hat von
Burkina Faso angeblich eine Mine als
Gegenleistung für die Unterstützung im
Kampf gegen sie hat extra Westen
erhalten wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt
was ist Putin ausgezeichnet in den Plan
dass die Warengruppe in Afrika Gold
abbaut um seinen Krieg in der Ukraine zu
finanzieren
Russland welche Rolle spielt die
wagnergruppe der russischen
zöllnertruppe wird vorgeworfen dies oder
diese schon Goldvorkommen geplünder zu
haben um die Operation in der Ukraine zu
finanzieren nachdem du dann kämpfe
ausgebrochen sind zwischen Armee und den
paramilitärischen
kommen Fragen über die Beteiligung der
wagnergruppe auf einer mächtigen
russischen zöllnerorganisation die seit
Jahren im Sudan aktiv ist die wahre
Gruppe hat im Sudan so richtig Fuß
gefasst als Oma albair noch am Drucker
war da der populäre Diktator damals
Angst hatte dass seine Macht wackelt ist
er 2017 nach Russland wird Putin gedüst
und hat ihn den Sudan als
russlandseingangstür nach Afrika
schmackhaft gemacht als Gegenleistung
wollte er russische Militärhilfe eine
russisches Bergbauunternehmen brachte
daraufhin seine Experten in den Sudan
der immerhin Afrikas drittgrößter
Goldproduzent ist die wagnergruppe
Schütze zunächst vor allem die
Goldvorkommen wurde jedoch während der
Protest sie gegen alvarier 2019 zu einem
direkten Akteur bei der Unterdrückung
der Demonstrationen doch auch das nutzte
albertieren nichts er wurde schließlich
aufgrund der mittlerweile außer
Kontrolle geratene Proteste durch
Generäle entmachtet danach
verschlechtete sich auch die Beziehung
zwischen brigochien und Armeechef alt so
dass die Partnergruppe wieder eher die
Rolle eines Security Truppe Einnahmen
allerdings handelt es sich um eine
äußerst lukrative Wächter Rolle so
schmuggelte ein Militärflugzeug
mindestens 16 Mal Gold von Sudan nach
Latakia Oma Russland Ukraine Invasion zu
finanzieren und das war nur die Spitze
des Eisbergs Russlands Interessen im
Sudan beschränken sich nämlich nicht nur
auf Gold Moskau steht kurz vor der
Bezeichnung eines Abkommens mit dem
Sudan über den Bau einer Militärbasis in
Port Sudan am Roten Meer im Gegenzug
wird Russland weitere
waffen-putins globale Agenda also ein
wirklich wichtiger Mann deswegen lässt
der Cremes Chef ihn auch des öfteren
Mahlwerk Ball über die Stränge schlagen
und genau aus diesem Grund ist auch sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass er ihn fallen
lässt und zwar auch wenn er ihn mal mehr
und mal weniger Privilegien gegenüber
reguläre Armee eingeräumt Wagner hat vor
kurzem nämlich eine enge Beziehung zur
paramilitärischen Truppe des vom
camillhändler zum General aufgestiegenen
Mohammed haben dann da Gallo aufgebaut
dessen sogenannte Rapid Support Force
kurz RSF hatte in der Vergangenheit
eigentlich immer zusammen mit der
regulären zu tunesischen Armee gegen die
Regierungen geputzt erst 2019 gegen
alvariert dann 2021 gegen die
Übergangsregierung die eigentlich die
Demokratie einführen sollte nun hat sich
gregorien zu tunesisches Ebenbild der
Gallo jedoch mit dem armenische
Hand einen Bürgerkrieg losgetreten
18 April 2023 Kämpfe im Sudan RSF und
Armee prallen in kartum den dritten Tag
aufeinander bei den Kämpfen der Armee
und einer paramilitärischen Gruppe den
Rapid Support forces RSF sind nach
Angaben der Ärzte Gewerkschaft rund 100
Menschen ums Leben gekommen laut volker
Perthes dem un-gesandten für den Sudan
wurden mehr als 1.800 Zivilisten und
Kämpfer verletzt er bezifferte die Zahl
der Todesopfer am Montag auf 185
Personen und damit höher als die Ärzte
Gewerkschaft zur Zeit Punkte Aufnahme
dieses Videos wurden laut dem
Notfallzentrum des tutanesischen
Gesundheitsministerium sogar schon
mindestens 270 Menschen getötet und mehr
als 2600 verletzt heftige Kämpfe haben
das öffentliche Leben in kartum und
anderen Städten zum Erliegen gebracht
wegen Luftangriffen dass du danesischen
Armee mussten in der Hauptstadt 39 von
59 Krankenhäusern ihren Betrieb
einstellen tausende von Zivilisten sind
aus der Hauptstadt geflogen laut
Augenzeugen berichten sind die Straßen
voller leichten weil sich aus Angst ins
Kreuz Feuer zu geraten niemand traut sie
wegzuräumen die wagnergruppe ist
höchstwahrscheinlich auch in den
aktuellen Kampf verwickelt um ihre
Präsenz zu erhalten und ihre großen
Geschäftsinteressen zu schützen wenn
auch nicht direkt mit eigenen Kämpfern
denn da galos RSF ist quasi eine
proxytruppe pregorians geworden neben
der Macht im Lande geht es in erster
Linie nämlich darum eine schmuggelrute
für das Gold aus dem Sudan nach Dubai
und dann nach Russland zu sichern und
zwar damit auf diesen Weg die Operation
der wagnergruppe in der Ukraine
finanziert werden können Anfang 2022 nur
einen Tag nach dem Beginn der russischen
Invasion in der Ukraine flogalo
höchstpersönlich nach Moskau und leitete
damit eine neue Phase in den Beziehungen
der RSF und Wagner ein die russischen
Söhne können derzeit deswegen noch nicht
mit vollem Einsatz direkt in die Kämpfe
eingreifen da sie vor einem Dilemma
stehen denn dazu müssen sie maßgebliche
Kräfte von das sudanesischen Grenze zur
Zentralafrikanischen Republik abziehen
und genau dort kontrolliert Russland
mehrere Goldmine es würde also die
bergbauoperation gefährden der Goldabbau
könnte in Stocken kommen ins ganzes
Business besteht eben aus zwei
unverzichtbaren Komponenten auf der
einen Seite den Minen und auf der
anderen der logist bis zum Transport des
Goldes nach Russland und der
Waffenlieferungen aus Russland an die
sudanesischen Verbündeten wenn sich der
Konflikt allerdings zu einem Bürgerkrieg
ausweiten sollte und pregorians
bergbauinfrastruktur ernsthaft bedroht
wäre wird er wohl keine andere Wahl
haben als eigene Truppen in die Schlacht
zu schicken
es gibt Berichte über verstärkte Wagener
Aktivitäten in der Region unter anderem
den Transport bestimmter Materialien von
libyschen Militärbasen in den Sudan die
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den RSF Milizen
den Streitkräften Wagners und den
Militäreinheit
besteht schon lange haftava ein enger
Verbündeter des Diktators Gaddafi kämpft
gegen die international anerkannte
Regierung seines Landes und kooperiert
sein langen mit Russland es wäre
ziemlich unangenehm für Russland wenn
das zu dann den Übergang zu einer
zivilen Regierung und zu demokratischen
Wahlen schaffen würde wenn die RS Erfolg
hat ist es wahrscheinlicher dass dies
nicht passieren wird gerade Anfang April
sollte ursprünglich das endgültige
Abkommen zwischen der zivilen und der
militärischen Führung des Sudan über den
Übergang zu einer Zivilregierung
unterzeichnet werden damit sollten
sowohl Metall bohrhahn als auch da Galo
die Macht abgeben und die sudanesischen
Institutionen neu geordnet werden doch
stattdessen kämpft das Land mit einem
Konflikt dessen Ende nicht absehbar ist
denn Russland und Wagner bevorzugen es
für die Stärkung ihres Einflusses in
Afrika wenn der rohstoffreiche Staaten
politisch instabil sind tja so weit so
schlecht an dieser Stelle werden sich es
aber sicher einige von euch fragen was
eigentlich Frankreich mit dieser ganzen
Situation im Sudan zu tun hat der Sudan
war doch früher eine britische Kolonie
keine französische und ja als
geschichtscanner habt ihr recht aber
seitdem ist eben viel geschehen Paris
hat seine Finger weit über France Afrika
hinaus ausgestreckt
Frankreich und die darfurkrise im Juli
2004 wieder setzte sich Paris den
Bemühungen der USA Sanktion gegen den
Sudan zu verhängen und erzwang die
Verabschiedung einer viel schwächeren
Resolution der Sicherheitsrats die
kartum lediglich mit Maßnahmen drohte
falls es nicht gegen die Milizen
Vorgehen würde die für die Gewalt in
davor verantwortlich gemacht werden
amerikanische frankreich-kritiker wie
Menschenrechtsaktivisten sind
gleichermaßen wütend was hat Frankreich
vor züniger fragen sich ob hinter der
französischen Politik der wun steht
seine Öl Interessen zu schützen einen
koloniales great game zu spielen oder
einfach die Vereinigten Staaten zu
ärgern damit wir uns noch mal
vergegenwärtigen wie alles mit allem
zusammenhängt von Paris über pekingen
bis Moskau und von Karton bis Kiel oder
die miese postkoloniale Politik
Frankreichs erscheint an dem Kampf gegen
den Terrorismus in der Region und die
dadurch weit verbreitete Unzufriedenheit
die Paris geschaffen hat hätte vieles
davon nicht so weit kommen müssen Afrika
wäre heute wohl viel stabiler Demokratie
hätte dort eine nicht so schweren
Standort wie autokratische Imperium
würden nicht so viele ein Pastoren
vorfinden okay so weit so schlecht aber
stimmt es denn dass dies ganz allein von
Frankreich verursacht wurde wie stark
war denn eigentlich die historische
Rolle Russlands nun frankreich hat eben
katastrophal schlecht abgeschnitten das
ist wahr aber gleichzeitig wusste
Russland eben seine Karten sehr gut zu
spielen von welchen Karten wir reden nun
von den Karten der Geschichte die
Propaganda des gremmels war sehr gut
darin die Afrikaner daran zu erinnern
der auf ihrer Seite war als sie für ihre
Unabhängigkeit gegen die Kolonialmächte
kämpften und dass ich diese Botschaft
durchgesetzt hat liegt zum Teil an der
wagnergruppe selbst denn wie wir euch
bereits in einem früheren Video gezeigt
haben dass ich euch verlinken werde hat
diese auch eine sehr starke
Marketingabteilung und war eben auch für
die politischen Marketingkampagne zu
Gunsten Russlands in all diesen Ländern
verantwortlich das Stichwort lautet
trollfarmen tatsächlich musste Facebook
seit Ende 2019 mehr als 300 konnten
schließen die mit Goschen in Verbindung
standen und mehr als 12 afrikanischen
Ländern russische Propaganda verbreitet
werden es ist also klar während China
Frankreichs wirtschaftlichen Boden
auffrisst ist Russland damit beschäftigt
es in Sicherheitsfragen zu verdrängen
die Frage ist also gibt Frankreich so
leicht auf tja nehmen wir diese
springende Frage doch lieber mal etwas
genauer unter die Lupe aufgepasst
eine notwendige Änderung des Kurses
inzwischen dürfte allen klar sein dass
das Image der granation in weiten Teilen
Afrikas katastrophal ist zugegeben es
gab Zeiten in denen Paris zu Unrecht
kritisiert wurde zum Beispiel als die
Franzosen ihre Truppen aus Mali abzogen
weil sie mir einfach beschuldigt wurden
den Kampf gegen die Terrorismus
aufzugeben obwohl es selbst war dass die
Franzosen rausgeschmissen hatte aber um
ehrlich zu sein macron weiß ganz genau
dass die Rolle die Frankreich in den
letzten Jahrzehnten in Afrika gespielt
hat oft verwerflich war und genau aus
diesem Grund definiert er jetzt seine
Strategie neu
die Regierung Macau hat sich in Afrika
bereits an die Arbeit gemacht und neue
Abkommen mit Ländern in der Region
ausgehandelt tatsächlich hat sie sich
bereits ab Anfang 2022 dazu verpflichtet
nach dem Vorbild Chinas in den Bau von
Infrastruktur zu investieren mit anderen
Worten frankreich will jetzt endlich das
tun was andere Länder bereits in der
Vergangenheit mit ihren Kolonien getan
haben
Frankreich schließt sich China bei
Infrastrukturprojekten an der Gallier
lernt langsam aber er lernt außerdem
will Frankreich angesichts des
Scheiterns der anti-terror-operation der
Sahelzone eine weitere langwierige
militäre Stationierung in Zukunft um
jeden Preis vermeiden aus diesem Grund
hat Paris unter anderem angeboten den
Bau von Militärakademien unter anderem
an der Elfenbeinküste und in Dschibuti
zu fördern darüber hinaus hat es in
bestimmten Situationen sogar logistische
geheimdienstliche und militärische
Unterstützung angeboten
macron scheint also verstanden zu haben
dass die von seinen Vorgängern verfolge
Strategie nicht funktioniert hat das
Image Frankreichs wurde in Afrika über
Gebühr beschädigt
in gewisser Weise sind die neuen
Maßnahmen die ihr vorschlägt sehr nah an
der klassischen softpower über die wir
hier auf visualpolitik bald ein sehr
interessantes eigenes Video bringen
werden mit anderen Worten es geht um
weniger Peitsche und mehr Zuckerbrot
also Abo und glücklich nicht vergessen
um es nicht zu verpassen die große
Preisfrage ist nämlich ob sich all dies
nicht dennoch als unzureichend erweisen
könnte und zwar angesichts eines
chinesischen Partner für den
afrikanischen Ländern einen
ehrgeizigeren Weg aufgezeigt hat und
russischer Söldner die scheinbar besser
in der Lage sind militärisch die Fäden
in der Hand zu halten unser ist nur um
an Gold und Diamanten Minen
heranzukommen im Sudan zumindest sind
die Franzosen viel zu spät zur versorge
kommen und mögen ihre verspäteten Gesten
des guten Willens noch so groß gewesen
sein
genau 5 Milliarden Dollar Frankreich
erlässt den Sudan alle Schulden
Frankreichs Präsident Emmanuel macron
will ein Paket zur massiven
Unterstützung Afrikas Schnüren dazu
greift er den zu damit gewaltigen Summen
unter die Arme auch Deutschland erlässt
im Land Verbindlichkeiten in
dreistelliger Millionenhöhe tatsache ist
nun mal das Frankreich viel zu spät
kapierter das es sich auf ein
multipolares Afrika einstellen muss in
dem es nicht mehr die eindeutig
dominierende Macht sein wird und zwar in
Afrika in dem nicht nur andere
Großmächte mitspielen sondern auch die
Afrikaner selbst nach und nach einem
Mitsprache bei den Entscheidungen über
ihr Schicksal einfordern uns wird dieser
riesige Kontinent über den wir bereits
einige wissenswerte Videos gedreht haben
und deren Links ihr in der Beschreibung
finden könnt sicherlich noch sehr oft
beschäftigen und bis dahin sind die
Fragen an Euch gerichtet inwieweit denkt
ihr ist Frankreich wirklich bereits ein
Umgang mit Afrika nach 200 Jahren zu
ändern wird Paris in der Lage sein seine
Einfluss doch noch irgendwie aufrecht zu
erhalten und wird es Russland gelingen
die Lücken zu füllen die die
französische Armee hinterlässt wie immer
sind auf eure Diskussion zu diesem Thema
schon mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht gelernt habt falls ja gibt
uns bitte ein Like und teilt dieses
Video mit euren Freunden um es mit ihnen
ausgiebig zu diskutieren natürlich
freuen uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
wie immer in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]